[Music]
[Applause]
and what i want to talk about today is
the event that we're going to be holding
on the 21st of may this is a fundraiser
that supports
veterans
here in southern nevada as well as our
youth organization the double pups of
southern nevada
this event is going to be held at sunset
park
and it starts at nine o'clock
and we give them three hours
to complete the race
so it's uh it's good for walkers and of
course runners as well
scott what makes this a fun family for
them well it's twofold one
event allows
and rewards those who are really
athletically inclined and
they'll get extra cards by
getting to the stations before other
people do but for the families you can
go out with
with your kids
and
hit these events and participate
together on this thing and spend a
couple hours in the the beauty of sunset
park in amongst the sand dunes finding
these locations coming back and taking a
chance and see if he
are able to win one of the big prizes
people can donate in two ways one we
have a gofundme page but another way
they can donate is by going on to our
website if they want to participate in
the run itself and that website is
marines memorial 5k.com
the reason this is important is we want
to hold an event that is going to be
popular and all the funds are going to
go to needy veterans
[Music]
[Applause]
we find our countries
[Music]